قالت مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه ان شابا
فلسطينيا استشهد اثر اصابته برصاص قوت
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحامها قريه
دير ابو ضعيف شرق مدينه جنين بالضفه
الغربيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني قال ان
قوات الاحتلال اطلقت الرصاص الحي نحو شبان
الفلسطينيين كما اندلعت
اشتباكات بين الشبان والقوات المقتحمه وسط
القريه لا اله الا
الله ونشر وسائل اعلام فلسطينيه عبر منصه
تيليغرام مشاهد لمقاله انها لاقتحام ليلي
نفذته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بلده
بيرزيت شمال رام
الله محمد خيري مراسل الجزيره ينضم الينا
من رام الله مرحبا محمد كيف تتطور الاوضاع
ميدانيا واقتحامات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تستمر في كثير من مناطق الضفه
الغربيه
نعم في اخر تطورات قبل قليل اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مخيم عين السلطان في
مدينه اريحا وانتشرت في احياء المخيم وهي
تحاصر احدى البنايات داخل المخيم في هذه
الاثناء وكذلك في مدن شمالي الضفه الغربيه
وخاصه في مدينه جنين استشهد شعب فلسطيني
في قريه دير ابو ضعيف التي اقتحمتها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من عده محاور وانتشرت
في عدد من احيائها وحاصرت عددا من المنازل
ثم اندلعت اشتباكات مع مواطنين فلسطينيين
واطلقت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الرصاص
الحي بجاه المواطنين ما ادى الى استشهاد
شاب واحد وبعد ذلك انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بعدما فتشت عددا من المنازل
وخربت محتوياتها وفي مدينه نابلس وخاصه في
قريه بيت فوريك اقتحمت ايضا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عددا من الاحياء وانتشرت قوات
راجله في شوارع البلده وكذلك حاصرت القوات
الاسرائيليه منازله وفتشتها ودهمت عددا من
منازل المواطنين الفلسطينيين واعتدت على
شبان فلسطينيين فيما شهدت ايضا مدينه
قلقيليه اقتحاما واسعا من قبل اليات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي توجهت الى حي
كفر سابه في وسط المدينه وهناك دخلت الى
عدد من البنايات واقتحمت عددا من المنازل
كذلك ودمرت وخربت ممتلكات المواطنين
الفلسطينيين واعتدت بالض على بعض الشبان
الفلسطينيين التطورات مستمره في الضفه
الغربيه ومن جنوبها الى شمالها ايضا منذ
السابع من اكتوبر وحتى هذا اليوم بشكل
واسع جدا وقد بلغت عدد حالات الاعتقال في
الضفه الغربيه والقدس اكثر من
6240 حاله اعتقال حتى اليوم محمد خيري
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من رام الله شكرا
جزيلا مره اخرى